موقف الرئيس الاوكراني من الاتحاد
السوفيتي ومن ثم روسيا لم يكن يوما وليدا
لحظه عداء بل تراكم منذ الصغر زينسكي
الرئيس لم يختلف يوما عن الطفل مواقف عده
رصدتها الفرنسيه
عكست تاثير نشاه على توجهاته وصراعه
الدائري مع روسيا مرحله الطفوله كان عمر
الطالب زيلنسكي عشره اعوام عام
1988 اثناء الاحتفال بثوره اكتوبر او
الثوره البلشفيه امر المعلم بوقوف الطلاب
في ساحه الشعله الابديه في بلدته ووفقا
الفرنسيه لا ينسى توبيخه مع زملائه بسبب
عدم كي الوشاح الاحمر لمنظمه الشباب
الشيوعي مرحله الشباب في شبابه اعتاد
زيلنسكي على الاحتفال امام النصب التذكاري
للجنود الذين حرروا مدينته عام
1944 وفي عام 2023 لم يتغير النصب
التذكاري وظل الذكرى تحرير بلدته من
النظام الشيوعي ترافق مشواره من الفن الى
السياسه رمزيه مسقط راس زلينسكي مدينه
كريفيريخ كانت مركزا مهما للمجهود الحربي
ايام التحدي الجمهوريات السوفيتيه وظلت
كذلك الى اليوم فلم يعد زلنسكي الى مسقط
راسه منذ بدء الحرب بسبب القصف المتواصل
عليها
لكل من الرئيسين الاوكراني والروسي مخزون
من ذكريات الماضي صور ضلت عالقه في
الاذهان وتظهر على السطح كل ما اشتدت حده
الصراع الروسي الاوكراني
علي السمان العربيه